there are few
[Music]
that would please
me interests me in fashion is to be
able to see what to pass a
message reminding that I make you a
lot more clothes to
pass a message precisely that
through simple clothes we
can  pass something as strong
as emotions
[Music]
my internship with a German brand
called assures only tobacco will shock
to say that Germans take the
time to come and talk to me when
I was 16 I was doing when  i was
just a notepad in germany but
the recess scene where it really looks like
what i eat i think finally i dream
maybe not had a chance like
that because people are very sloping
are no longer in  more of my clients all
over fashion they are very scared
to trust people in me
[Music]
my idea for mistakes it's
so much it's from them that i
build them deconstruct to
rebuild and that every piece
i  I cut then knew  use myself
for something else without adding to
the adversary
because for me I am my my state
of mind is that for me the
destruction allows the creation offered
in the hand people dare more in
France are afraid of  to be judged in
germany there are many people who
dare ddd hairstyle a little strong
me i find i don't see
whatever shocking is hot this saturday
nuremberg that she is in fact say
as necessary
in fact it's just it's  because she
has an outfit in fact there an outfit in
several different colors that's
all
[Music]
i think that germany is my strength
i do
n't know  right because it's
important that people there and they
are crazy to boot i'm good where you are
you there and i was checked by policemen
almost every day in the metro
because what i like a little more
tattoos for example because I have
money donations
it's true  nt what i like in
germany what people are so
mother only open-minded exit
and its caracas machine thanks to sylvain
tur that i was able to work for
a german bank and still
today i work for them  but
it's really interesting to see
how much in the same environment of their
same fields of work
it's good the countries were different